KENT WALKER: Good
afternoon, everybody.
I'm Kent Walker.
I just wanted to
briefly introduce
Phil Howard, who's here with
us to talk about his new book,
"The Rule of Nobody."
This is a topic that's of lots
of concern to people at Google.
Trying to take a look at
government regulations, how
they've evolved over the years.
Even as we try and
move forward with a lot
of cutting-edge technology,
ranging from the internet kinds
of tools to driverless cars and
genetics and everything else,
we're keenly aware
of the challenges
in dealing with
existing laws and trying
to move those laws
forward in a positive way.
Just yesterday, we got a
ruling from the European Court
of Justice, interpreting a
large body of European law
in ways that are
somewhat challenging
for the good function
of the internet.
So Phil has been working
on this topic for years.
He's written multiple
books in the area.
It's an interesting area.
There's a confluence of
people on the left, people
on the right, who are
concerned about the state
that we found ourselves
in almost inadvertently
as a result of the growth
of regulations, many of them
well intended, but not
working out the way
that we would all like to.
So with that, let me
turn it over to Phil.
He's going to be
here for the hour,
and I think has a couple
books here as well.
So if people are
interested, I would
encourage you to have an
active Q and A back and forth,
even though I won't be able
to stay for the whole session.
Phil?
PHILIP HOWARD: Great.
Thank you, Kent.
And thanks for coming.
I had this insight, really
a brilliant insight,
shared by 98% of Americans,
that the government
wasn't working very well.
And so I set out in this
book, "The Rule of Nobody,"
to try to understand what
structure would enable
government to work better again.
And what I concluded
is that we are actually
at a troubling place in the
history of our aging democracy.
And what's happened
is that we're
unable to make choices, even
the most obvious choices.
Democracy's has
lost the capacity
to choose, make choices, move
forward, adapt, and keep going.
And I also concluded that the
problem is not bad leadership,
although leadership
has not been great.
Nor is the problem mainly
polarized politics.
I actually think the
polarization of politics, which
is horrible, in
Washington is mainly
a symptom of
powerlessness rather than
the cause of this
paralysis that we see.
That when people feel that
they don't have the power
to make choices, what's left is
to point fingers at each other.
And they become
ever more strident
because they know nothing
is going to happen.
They can propose the
most idiotic ideas
with full confidence.
But again, nothing will
happen in our democracy.
What's happened is we have
a structural problem, which
is that the law has piled
up decade after decade,
usually for very good
reasons, but nobody ever
goes back to clean it out
or make sure it's working.
And so like sediment
in the harbor,
it's gotten to the point
where people in government
can't actually do even what
they think they should do.
So just a few stories.
A couple of years ago,
a tree fell in the creek
in Franklin
Township, New Jersey.
It caused flooding.
The town fathers sent in
a backhoe to pull it out.
Then the lawyer
for the town said
no, you can't do
that because it's
a class C1 creek,
whatever that is.
And you're going to
have to get approval
to remove any natural obstacle
from a class C1 creek.
So they had to go start
filling out forms.
SPEAKER 3: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP HOWARD: OK.
So I just keep going?
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, keep going.
PHILIP HOWARD: Yeah, OK.
Great.
So 12 days and over $12,000
in legal fees later,
they were able to get permission
to do what was obvious
and pull the tree
out of the creek.
Now, that's just an incident.
An anecdote.
Anecdotes don't prove anything.
In February, the White House
issued a five year report
on the 2009 stimulus plan
which, as you will recall,
involved $800 billion--
that's almost $3,000
for every man, woman, and
child in America-- to stimulate
the economy.
And the bell cow
of this program was
to rebuild America's decrepit
infrastructure, which
really needs rebuildling.
We have 100-year-old
sewage lines.
Bridges-- one out
of nine bridges
in danger of falling down.
So we had bipartisan support.
We spent $800 billion.
Five years later, the report.
I was curious to
see how much of it
was spent to rebuild
infrastructure.
And then buried in
the back of the chart
was this number-- barely
3% of the $800 billion
was spent to rebuild
transportation infrastructure.
You say, well,
how could that be?
Why so little?
Well, it turned out that the
president of the United States,
duly elected by the
majority of Americans,
with bipartisan support
for this program,
did not have the
authority to approve even
the most obvious
rebuilding project.
We're not talking about
roads through virgin forest.
We're talking about
just fixing up
old roads and highways and such.
The density of regulation
today cannot be overestimated.
I tell the story
at the beginning
of the book of
the Bayonne Bridge
was needed to be
either torn down
or something happened
to let [INAUDIBLE]
ships come into Newark Harbor.
The roadway was 70 feet too low.
A lifetime government employee
had the idea, a brilliant idea,
of actually just
raising the roadway
of this existing
80-year-old bridge.
It turned out structurally,
you could do that.
Save $3 billion.
Use the same foundation,
same right of way.
No environmental impact.
Four years later, they
got their approval.
And then the litigation started
over whether there was adequate
review in the 5,000-page
environmental review statement
for a project with no
environmental impact.
And you say, what could
they have studied?
Well, the law requires
them to send notices
to all the Native American
tribes that might have once
had contact with this
area of New Jersey.
So they're sending letters
to the Shawnee Indians,
and Nebraska, and
such, and ask if they
want to participate
in the process.
Another requirement
was they had to do
a study of all
historic buildings
within a 2 mile radius of
either side of the bridge,
even though in this case,
the project would not
touch any buildings.
Using the same right of way.
Same [INAUDIBLE].
And so on and on and on.
And that's the way
law works today.
These requirements just
piled up decade after decade.
It's not just getting
approvals either.
The most fundamental
choices of democracy,
like how we spend our money, is
all preset in legal concrete.
60% of federal revenue goes
to three very important
entitlement programs
that we can't
afford in their current form.
They don't even come to
Congress for authorization.
Andrew Cuomo, when he
became governor-- New York,
like most states, had
budgetary problems--
discovered that there was a
juvenile detention facility
upstate with no juveniles in it.
It cost $50 million
a year to operate.
He had a public
announcement, we're
going to save the taxpayers
of New York $50 million
by closing down this facility.
Not so fast.
There's a law in New York
that says you can't close down
a public facility with any
union employees without at least
one year's notice.
So we had to spend
another $15 million--
that's 10,000 taxpayers
each paying $5,000 a year
in taxes-- to pay
for a facility that
had served the public
good not at all.
And it's not just government
that's paralyzed by this.
Society is.
Technology companies have not
suffered as much from this
because you're in
a new industry.
You're beginning
to see it happen
in privacy and lots
of other areas,
like the ruling
yesterday from the EU.
But other.
The most rudimentary,
starting a restaurant.
Opening a restaurant in
New York requires approval
from 11 different agencies.
In the US today, and in recent
rankings by the International
Monetary Fund, US
ranks 20th in the world
in ease of starting a business.
This is United
States of America.
20th in the world.
And it's just because
of the [INAUDIBLE]
licensing laws, regulations.
The Bayonne Bridge
project I mentioned
required 47 permits from
19 different agencies
to get permission to raise
a roadway of a project that
had enormous environmental
benefit and economic benefit
to the region.
And finally, this rule-based,
the [INAUDIBLE] of law,
is changing the culture.
Couple of months ago,
after I was in galleys,
a long time District of
Columbia parks employee
was walking with his daughter.
He had a heart attack in
front of a fire station in DC.
The firemen where watching.
They're standing there.
They're first responders.
The daughter ran over and said,
my father's gasping for breath.
I think he had a heart attack.
Can you come help?
And they said, no.
The proper rule is to call 911.
And she said, but he's
gasping for breath.
No, the rule is to call 911.
They called 911.
They watched.
By the time the ambulance
arrived, he was dead.
This is not an unusual story.
A couple of years ago
in Alameda County here,
a mother called
the fire department
and said her son was off his
meds, was very depressed,
was going to commit suicide.
Said he was going
to commit suicide
by going to a certain
beach and just
swimming out until he drowned.
So sure enough, the firemen
show up on the beach.
And here's this guy treading
water 100 yards offshore.
And they stand there and watch.
And the crowd
gathers on the beach.
Said, why don't you go help him?
And they say, well,
because of budget cuts,
we haven't been recertified
for land-based rescue.
[INAUDIBLE]
Finally one bystander dives
in the water, cold water.
Goes in, tries to save him.
Gets here too late.
Brings in the body.
This hit the newspapers.
The next day, the fire chief
was asked, what would you
have done if that
was a child drowning?
And he said, well, I know what
I would do if I was off duty.
But if I was on duty, I'd
have to follow the rules.
So think about this
society we built,
where the president
of the United States
can't approve the most
obvious and needed projects
for our society.
And so they end up wasting most
of the $800 billion to shore up
insolvent state debt
budgets, basically.
Not rebuilding
the infrastructure
that desperately
needs to get rebuilt.
And you have firemen
not saving lives
because the rules
don't let them do it.
So is this how democracy's
supposed to work.
And I said to him, no.
Is that how the rule of
law's supposed to work?
I don't think so.
Rule of law's supposed to
support a free society,
not remove our freedom
to make sense of things.
In the 1930s, Harry
Hopkins-- there
was a law past to
stimulate the economy.
There was the Civilian
Works Administration.
It was passed in November.
By the end of December,
Harry Hopkins who ran it,
had hired 2.6 million people
in less than seven weeks.
It's not like this
is rocket science.
People have to be able
to make choices and take
responsibility.
But what we've
created, this world,
where in essence at this
point, because of the decretion
of law, democracy's
basically run by dead people.
It's run by whoever
wrote all these laws
and wrote all these
regulations over the years.
And it piled up.
And now people go to work and
they say, what do I have to do?
And they go and noses
in the rule books.
And these people
who are long gone.
We wouldn't know who they
were even if you tried
to find them are
telling us what to do.
And who is responsible?
Who is responsible for the
fact that we couldn't spend
the $800 billion to
rebuild the infrastructure?
Nobody.
Who is responsible for
the budget deficit?
Nobody.
Who was responsible for
any of these idiocies?
Nobody.
Nobody's in charge.
So we have two structural flaws.
One of them relates to
our aging democracy,
which is we don't
have the capacity,
or even the idea--
or the capacity--
to go back and adjust old laws.
It's nowhere part of
our public debate.
The laws get passed.
The people,
legislatures, let them
set sail towards
immortality, treating them
like they're the '10
commandments or something,
except it's the 10 million
commandments at this point.
Not understanding that
there's a big difference
between basic principles of
law, like the reasonable person
standard, or don't commit
fraud, or things like that,
and these social programs,
the regulatory programs,
were highly complex, that
affect human behavior, that
reflect priorities at the
time they were enacted.
And all those things change.
And all of them have
unintended consequences.
There's not one
law that's passed
that doesn't have
unintended consequences.
One example.
Special ed laws were
enacted in 1975.
Very important.
Before we had them, we
locked disabled kids up
and horrible places
like Millbrook.
So we passed this
law in a certain way.
It evolves, however,
over the decades,
until now special ed consumes
over 25% of the total K to 12
budget in America.
There's virtually no
money for gifted children.
money for early education.
Is that the right balance?
No one's even
asking the question.
So we have no mechanism
for going back and adapting
old law.
It's a formula for failure,
just that by itself.
Compounding the problem
and causing the paralysis
is that we have a deliberate
philosophy that humans
shouldn't be allowed
to make public choices.
Believe it or not,
that is our philosophy.
And it's shared by both
the right and the left,
the concept of
rationalized completeness.
That whatever government
gets its hands on,
it should tell people
exactly how to do things.
Not just what too do.
Not just have a reasonably
safe facility, or that
and inspectors come by and
have discussions and arguments
or whatever.
But actually telling people
exactly what kind of equipment
to use.
Exactly how to do it.
Nursing homes.
I talk a lot about
nursing homes.
Nursing homes in
most states have
typically about 1,000 rules.
Food should be stored no
less that 50 centimeters
above the floor.
Hot food should be served
not less than 150 degrees.
Residences should be an
average of 80 square feet.
There's to be 0.09
recreational workers.
[INAUDIBLE] trash cans
shall be in the bathroom.
Eggs shall be cooked.
The level of the granular
detail of these rules is absurd.
And they don't help.
They hurt because
people go to work
trying to comply
with the rules, not
trying to make the
residents' lives better.
People say, well, what
else could you do?
Well in fact, Australia
a couple of decades
ago had the same problem
with nursing homes.
They had 1,000 rules.
They got rid of all the rules.
They replaced them
with 31 principles.
Have a home-like setting.
Respect the dignity
of the residents.
All the experts scoffed.
And they said, these
nursing home operators
are going to get
away with murder.
It's horrible.
Within the year, the nursing
homes were all twice as good.
So the experts went and
studied why is that.
Because people actually went
to work asking the question,
what's the right thing to do?
Regulators didn't give
up their authority.
They could still close down a
place if it was abusive or not.
And you could still have
arguments and courts
could resolve them if
you had an argument.
But now the argument was over
what's right and what's wrong.
Not the parsing of legal
language and a 1,000 rules.
So one of the horrors of
modern detailed regulation
is it divorces regulation
from right and wrong.
The Constitution
was 10 pages long.
The Volcker Rule
implementing one little part
of the Dodd-Frank
financial regulation law
to regulate proprietary
trading by banks--
the Volcker Rule
is 980 pages long.
Do you think they're going to be
talking about right and wrong?
No.
Hundreds of lawyers
in the banks.
Hundreds of lawyers at the
Department of the Treasury.
And they're going to be arguing
over legal parsing of language.
But doesn't it mean this?
Wouldn't in this situation
it really be a hedge?
What does the word hedge mean.
It's just there is no set of
words that avoids ambiguity.
And by trying to create
a legal system that
avoids ambiguity because
we don't want anybody
to make a mistake,
what we've done
is instead driven people into
this world in which everyone
acts like idiot savants.
Nobody's talking about
what's right and wrong.
No one's taking
responsibility to do
rather on the public
side or the other side.
So we have this
structural problem.
And I don't think
we can repair it.
You can't send
some brilliant guy
like [INAUDIBLE] in the
White House and say,
let's have different motivations
in this area of the law.
It's like going into the
Amazon jungle with some shears.
The law at this point, there
are over 100 million words
of binding federal
law and regulation,
and growing every year.
Over 2 billion words if
you combine all the state
regulation with it.
No one knows it all.
No one in a school knows all
the rules that apply to schools.
So you can't actually
go in and edit it.
You need a new philosophy.
And I think the
philosophy should
be one based on
human responsibility
and accountability.
Should be generally
principles-based
for human behavior.
You still have
speed limit that can
be detailed or effluent
limits for a solution.
But in many areas of
government oversight,
they should always
leave from judgement.
Always room for the question.
So what are the solutions?
One solution is to
do a spring cleaning.
It's happened periodically
through history.
It's called a recodification.
We did it in the 1950s
with commercial law.
Something called the
Uniform Commercial Code
was put together by
a group of experts
to replace this madcap will to
inconsistent, complicated state
contract laws in the
48 states at the time.
And it was the foundation for
the postwar economic boom.
Everybody knew where they
stood with contract law.
The set of principles
that people could study.
It could be
interpreted by courts.
It was like replacing a muddy
road with a paved highway.
If you go in and recodify law
that's built up over the ages,
it always has that effect.
It had that affect in Germany
at the end of the 19th century.
It had that effect when
Napoleon recodified the law
and created the Napoleonic
Code, which is now
the basis for half the
civilized world's law.
Fantastic achievement in
the early 19th century.
It happened in ancient
times with Justinian.
We can't fix this problem
without doing that.
And the second
thing we have to do
is we have to radically simplify
doing [INAUDIBLE] the law
and turn it.
And understand that law's
supposed to be a corral.
It sets goals, principles.
Sometimes it has rules.
But within the corral,
humans, both the regulator
and the regulated,
always need to have
room to ask the question,
how do we make sense of this?
How do we make something work?
It shouldn't be an
instruction manual.
It should be the opposite
of instruction manuals.
It should be something where
people take responsibility
and are accountable
when they fail.
We need, going
forward, sunset laws
because the founders
made a mistake.
They didn't realize it would
be 100 times harder to get rid
of a law than to pass it.
As soon as a law's
enacted, it's surrounded
by an army of special interest.
All of Washington is dedicated,
all of that machinery
is dedicated to the status quo.
That's their job.
Just have nothing change.
So is any of this feasible?
Why are we even
talking about this?
Congress can barely
raise the debt ceiling
to avoid a default
on the national debt.
Why are we talking
about these big ideas?
Well, the answer is
nothing's feasible.
But what the political
scientists say,
it's precisely in these periods
that pretty soon, everything
is going to be possible.
Pressures build up over decades.
This is the path of history.
Change never happens
with small ball.
It always happens in big gulps.
The change, the
pressures build up.
And then like the stick-slip
phenomenon of earthquakes,
something happens.
Some street vendor
self-immolates in Tunisa
and it sets off some revolution.
The Arab Spring, in that case.
So we're going to have--
and in fact, we're overdue.
This has happened in American
history usually every 30 years.
It happened in the 1960s.
We changed our values.
Completely changed
our legal structure
to address problems that
we'd been ignoring for years.
It happened in the 1930s
with social safety nets.
It happened in the
progressive era,
when we got rid of laissez-faire
and finally started
regulating rapacious companies
that were destroying children
in their factories.
It happened in the Civil War
in getting rid of slavery,
but that followed decades
of work by the abolitionists
before Lincoln led the change.
It happened with
Jacksonian democracy.
So we're going to have change.
But change is not always good.
It can happen like the Arab
Spring or the French Revolution
or something.
So what I'm trying
to do with this book
is argue that we have a problem.
We have problems not
just with policy,
when are we going to deal
with climate change, things
like that.
We have a problem with
institutional design.
We have a democracy
that can't make choices,
either at the smallest
level, removing the tree
from the creek, or
at the biggest level,
to balancing the budget
and changing priorities.
And we're not even
having a debate
about how to create the
institutional design.
Instead, reform
groups, I believe,
are canceling each other out.
Climate change, budget hawks.
All these people, they're
just competing for airtime.
And I have a piece coming
out in the "Washington Post"
this week [INAUDIBLE].
What's needed is
a master coalition
of people concerned about the
paralysis of our government
coming together, talking
about this meta-problem, which
is how do we make choices again.
And it's going to require a kind
of decade-long spring cleaning
to do this.
Nothing in the
history of the world
has ever happened because
somebody followed a rule.
It's just nothing
gets accomplished.
[INAUDIBLE] get accomplished
because people followed rules.
Nothing does.
Nothing happens
in your household
because you follow a rule.
Things happen because
people take responsibility
to make them happen.
Rules are really important
in a free society
to make people feel comfortable.
Provide a framework for
common choices and such.
But we can't create
a legal system
that's devoid of
human hands, that
avoids the possibility,
indeed, the inevitability,
of human error.
And we have to mechanisms
to deal with that.
But we can never move forward
until we can make new choices.
Our government is
not going anywhere.
Washington's not
going to fix it.
It's broken.
Every American knows it.
And the only way it's going
to get fixed, I believe,
is if Americans get together,
leaders of business, leaders
of not-for-profits, citizens
get together and force
the change on them.
Because it's become
anti-human and it's
become disconnected
from everyone.
And whose fault is it?
Nobody's.
Thanks very much.
SPEAKER 3: There's some
time for some questions
if you all may have any.
Yeah?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks a lot for your talk.
I think you're really making
some excellent points.
But it seems like you're
fighting a lot of things.
Every time there's a
hurricane, the first thing
the CNN cameras are asking
is, well, why wasn't there
a government law to prevent
X, Y, and Z. We recently
lost the Malaysian airplane,
and we're asking, well,
why didn't we have X,
Y, and Z communications?
So it seems that our reaction in
24 hour news and a whole bunch
of other things are
fighting against this.
That's one question I have.
So if we want to get moving
on this, how do we get moving?
What are the steps?
What's happened
previously in history?
How do we crack through it?
Because I think you're right on.
This is causing all
kinds of problems,
from people in their house being
able to make reasonable choices
with their family to all the
way companies, government,
lots of different things.
PHILIP HOWARD: We have
to change the narrative.
There needs to be a new way.
So one of the things I'm
trying to talk to people about
is a marketing plan.
Literally a marketing plan.
Just like marketing
anything else.
You have a plan that you have
people who carry the message.
They can be-- Jeb
Bush endorsed my book.
rousing endorsement last week.
Bill Bradley I think
is going to endorse it.
People from both
parties begin to do it.
You use that as a leader.
Maybe we can get
some movie stars.
And then you start sending
out direct mail or Google
equivalent of direct
mail, and start
selling the idea that we
need fundamental change.
That we need to get together
to force Washington to act.
The hardest thing
in history is when
a society gets to be too rich.
And people think that
Washington, the government's
over there.
I have a nice life.
Somebody else will
solve the problem.
That isn't happening.
And the Tea Party, in a sense,
is kind of constructive.
They have the wrong solutions.
They're right the
government's broken.
But there is that sense, that
kind of popular sense, that we
need to come together to make
it work again-- is essential.
We just need to have a
better idea about how
to fix it and restore
responsibility
rather than in their case,
just blow it up and do away
with government.
AUDIENCE: And I
guess the examples
that you gave in the beginning
are illustrative of that.
And it's a way that
we can actually
use media and other things
to turn this problem around.
Whenever there's a case of
someone drowning because
of some regulation, this
should be what's on the news
rather than making more
laws about other things.
PHILIP HOWARD: Yeah.
So just on that point,
every time there's a crisis,
there will be a natural instinct
to say, why isn't there a law?
And they'll pass a law.
And often that's very
hard to overcome.
It's just overwhelming.
That's just going to
be the first reaction
of any legislator.
So what's needed
more than getting
rid of that, which is probably
hard to do in all cases,
is a year later, the
process by which you then
take away the law.
And you say it's not working
or it's counterproductive.
Again, we don't have
that discussion.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So you mentioned earlier
that tech is just
now starting to feel the pain.
So one example was as you
know, Google sent five people
to go help fix the
healthcare.gov website.
And I feel like anyone who's
ever worked with government
contracts know there's this
huge pile of paperwork that
let's the government decide
how to pick contracts.
And it's very bloated.
And I think healthcare.gov
had 20 different vendors that
were hired just to
build one website.
Have you done any
work with that space
as far as reform or less rules
on who the government can
hire to build something
like a website?
That's been done multiple
times in the Bay Area.
PHILIP HOWARD: They're
called procurement laws.
And I was an adviser to
Al Gore and Bill Clinton
in redoing the procurement laws
and the reinventing government
campaign of 20 years ago.
So I worked very closely.
I gave speeches, [INAUDIBLE].
And they made a
few improvements,
including, for
example, not having
to go through those
idiotic processes
when you want to go
buy a pad of paper.
So they gave public employees
credit cards [INAUDIBLE]
go buy office supplies.
A minor reform.
But believe it or not,
that was a reform.
But they haven't fixed
it for big procurement.
Things like healthcare.gov
and so forth.
The government spends--
I forget the numbers--
it's over $500 billion a year
in outside government contracts.
Best estimates are they waste
between 30% and 40% of it
through these procedures
that basically
try to prescribed in advance how
the-- so they literally specify
in advance how you're going
to create the website instead
of letting smart engineers get
in a room, and work through
and adapt to all the problems.
It's a form of mental illness
to think that you can actually
accomplish anything
by writing in advance
and then saying just go do it.
I happened to be on the
plane last night out there
with the head of a
division of Boeing.
And we were discussing the
problems of procurement
and why it's so hard to get
good products at a good price
through this process.
I have another friend,
a high school classmate,
who's the deputy
head of procurement
at the Department of Defense.
He gives speeches to hundreds
of procurement officials,
saying, please
use your judgment.
Please be flexible.
But you have this whole culture
of nobody using their judgment.
That area truly needs
to get replaced.
It needs to get replaced by
a system where you identify
an official, that works
underneath him, that
is in charge of letting the
contract because no one's going
to trust him.
You maybe have an industry
committee of people [INAUDIBLE]
industries who have the
authority to review and reverse
contracts, something like that.
And it would happen in
the third of the time
and save all that money.
It's broken.
There's not one government
program that isn't broken.
Let's go there.
The question's whether
it's broken 25% or 95%.
That one's broken about 65%.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For every rule
I think that's out there,
if there isn't sort of a
vested minority interest
that's keeping it alive, even
though it should be extinct,
there might have been a
transgression at some point.
So for example, where
in the nursing homes,
you have to cook the eggs or the
food has to be above 35 inches,
I imagine at some point,
someone did something wrong
and it turned into a lawsuit.
So I'm wondering to what extent
there has to be tort reform
or the law needs to
change so that it's not
such a lawyer, sue-happy
culture and so [INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIP HOWARD: That's really,
really important point.
There's a general
instinct by people
to avoid responsibility
in general.
So if they have an excuse
to avoid responsibility,
they will.
It's like people
in Plato's cave.
As long as you feed us, we're
happy to be down in the cave.
The fear of litigation.
What the fire chief in
Alameda County said,
[INAUDIBLE], I can't
go in the ocean.
There might be liability.
Liability to who?
For saving a life?
You think about it
for one nanosecond
and you think, well, that's
the dumbest thing you've ever.
But he said it.
So there is this kind
of abstract fear,
which I have
written a lot about.
The problem with the system of
civil justice in this country
isn't that juries are
so stupid or whatever.
It's that now waves
of defensiveness
have overcome all of society.
Teachers will no longer put
an arm around a crying child.
My law firm has a
rule, as every business
does-- I think Google
does too-- that you're not
allowed to give a job reference.
It's so stupid.
This is the land of
the First Amendment.
You're not allowed to
give a job reference?
You get scared
you might get sued
if you say some
qualifying fact that's
honest about an employee?
So yes, we do.
And I talk about
this in the book.
At the end of the
book, I have a bill
of responsibilities
that basically clarifies
the responsibilities
of different branches
of government.
And with courts, I say
that basically no lawsuit
should be allowed to
go forward until judge
has made a legal ruling about
whether the claims should be
allowed to go forward
and won't undermine
the freedoms of other
people in the society.
Because now we have this kind
of laissez-faire attitude
of justice.
Well, you've got a right to sue.
People say that.
Suing is not an act of freedom.
Suing is an act of state power.
Sue somebody, you win,
you take away their home.
The sheriff comes and
takes away their home.
We have, again, it's like
another one of these things
where we've inverted
the role of law.
So the whole point of lawsuits
is that they're lawsuits.
Not like sue for
anything, [INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, it's a really important
reform to go on [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks a lot for your talk. .
I'm wondering how
much of this problem
is the result of the
violation of the principle
of subsidiarity, where
decisions and things ought
to be made at the
lowest possible level.
And the higher levels, like
the federal government,
is getting involved in
things at the states
ought to be handling.
And the states are
getting involved in things
that the local government
ought to be handling.
PHILIP HOWARD: Really
important question.
So there's a doctrine
that originated
I think in the Catholic church
that responsibility should
be pushed down to the
lowest possible level
so that people on the
ground owned their choices.
And since they own
their community,
they own their schools
and such, rather
than having top-down
bureaucracies rule
to the ultimate centralization,
where in this case,
dead people tell you what
to do because they wrote
a rule 30 years ago [INAUDIBLE].
And I talk about
subsidiarity in the book.
So one of the solutions
here while you're
doing the spring cleaning is to
the greatest extent possible,
push down decisions
to a local level.
That doesn't mean you
give up oversight.
It doesn't mean people can do
whatever they want and teach
creationism or whatever people
fear they're going to do.
But the regulations
should be much lighter.
Right now, you have
regulation, a rule of law.
This big iron claw comes
down into everybody's lives,
in their schools, and
in their communities.
You need to lift up
that big iron claw.
Let people do their own ways.
And only get involved if people
really leave the reservation.
They really leave the corral.
Again a really important
point because Americans
no longer feel they
own their communities.
And there are a lot
of studies of this.
And the truth is they don't.
If you're a retired physicist
or a retired software engineer
and you want to go work
in the schools, you can't.
You're much better qualified
than anybody in the school,
but you're not certified
to be a teacher.
Sorry.
If you want to go help
in a hospice, you can't.
Are you certified?
All these bureaucratic
constraints
prevent real people
who are qualified
for getting involved
in their communities.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PHILIP HOWARD:
[INAUDIBLE] question here?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PHILIP HOWARD: We have one
more for the cameraman.
[INAUDIBLE] this question.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
actually was an educator.
And you talked about education--
I was a special education
teacher.
And we got a significant
part of the budget.
But the other thing
I seem to find
is, is that more and more
students were then identified
as being special needs students.
And it seemed like there
was a significant portion
of the community that felt
served by what some of us
thought was a broken system.
So how do you address
the people that
feel served, even
though it's broken?
PHILIP HOWARD: You have
to make common choices.
Special ed, according to
some studies I've seen,
has twice the number of people
than it ought to have in it.
It becomes a place where
you get special training.
You get more time
to take your test.
There are all
kinds of advantages
to being designated
into special ed.
You can't run a democracy by
the lowest common denominator.
You can't have environmental
reviews that last ten years.
Germany, a much greener
country, [INAUDIBLE] last one,
two years at the
most because they
have a decision-maker
who says, OK.
We [INAUDIBLE].
Now we're going to have to this.
This official has
a responsibility
to make a decision.
And that can be appealed to
that official and that's it.
And the budget in schools is
a limited amount of dollars.
I think we need
in inner cities--
the experts I've talked to think
we need a dramatic redirection.
Not to pre-K education,
but to prenatal education.
Really getting these
kids and their mothers
before they're born so they can
develop language skills and all
the things that happen in
the first couple of years.
That's expensive.
Where does the money come from?
So we have to make these
choices in our society.
And if it's all preset in legal
concrete, we can't [INAUDIBLE].
One more question.
AUDIENCE: So I think served
is one aspect to people
who feel served by the laws.
But I think also
there's an aspect
of people being
scared by change.
So the more we talk
about this, like
you just mentioned
the physicists.
So you excited all the
physicists in the room.
But you just scared
millions of teachers
because they are comfortable
with the current law.
When you talk about
balancing the budget
and you talk about the three
big programs, well, OK.
So Social Security and Medicare.
You just scared a whole
'nother group of people.
And we can go on and on.
The more we talk about this,
basically everyone in this room
is going to be scared--
well, maybe not.
The percentage of people
that are going to be scared
is already about 50% just based
on the current conversation.
PHILIP HOWARD:
And probably more.
It's an excellent question.
First of all, change is scary.
Again, we go back
to Plato's cave.
They didn't want to
go out in the light.
They wanted to stay shackled
as much as they could.
Just be where they are.
So it's an evolutionary
imperative.
We have food in our stomachs.
People will never go
out to risk the world
of saber-toothed tigers
and converging technology
companies.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
So change is scary.
But the status
quo is also scary.
And so one of the
many things that's
missing in our current
dialogue about our society
are people who have
moral authority.
So what's really important is
for people stand up and say not
I'm going to get rid of
special ed the way it is,
but to say we're going to
remake a whole bunch of things.
And you're going to be
better off [INAUDIBLE].
But everybody's going
to have to sacrifice.
Because this huge
bureaucratic law,
we're all feeding off of it.
So we're scared to
lose the feeding off
of this big bureaucratic law.
But it's also suffocating us.
And it's not sustainable
because we can't afford it.
We're running half trillion
to trillion dollar deficits
every year.
We can't address climate change.
We can't address immigration,
bad immigration law.
We can't address anything.
So how do you do that?
Well, you need a group that
isn't vindictive and says,
I'm going to get
you, which is sort
of what both groups are about.
You need people
with moral authority
the people trust to be saying
what they really believe.
You don't have to agree with it.
And I challenge you to find
any public leader or even any
public citizen-- maybe you can
find a couple [INAUDIBLE]--
who have moral authority.
Because the way we've organized
our dealings with government,
even environmental groups
look like special interest.
They just want to do that.
They don't want to fix all
the other things to do.
[INAUDIBLE].
So we need to pull back.
This is a daunting problem.
And there's a
wonderful anarchist
called Peter Kropotkin.
He wrote 100 years ago.
He was a White Russian.
Fled the revolution.
Got a job writing for the
Encyclopedia Britannica.
If it were now, he would be
working for Google for sure.
Was a brilliant guy.
Wrote these hysterical tracts.
And he said, the more
miserable a man is,
the more he fears change lest it
make him more miserable still.
And so we do have to fight
human nature in doing it.
Everything I'm saying requires
fighting with human nature.
That doesn't mean
that' it's right.
It just means we
got to deal with it.
Thank you.